ganz europa zittert natürlich übermorgen
entscheidet frankreich über das
schicksal der eu marine le pen und der
front national am ende triumphieren
dann war es das wohl für den euro sie
profitieren ja seit gestern garantiert
wieder vom anschlag der kranken
islamisten ihrer brüder im geiste
was kommt da auf uns zu im worst case
mit der front national
um das herauszufinden haben wir lutz van
der horst ins deutsch französischen
grenzgebiet geschickt
ich stehe hier auf der freundschafts
brücke zwischen kehl und straßburg den
umfragen entsprechend ist deutschland
links und frankreich recht um
herauszufinden wie die rechten franzosen
ticken besuche ich den front national
chef des elsass laurent venedig venedig
fahrern wie mancher mit dem schicksal
das sie die deutsche staatsangehörigkeit
nur um ein paar meter verfehlt haben ist
das jetzt eine eine für mich ärgerlich
oder wieso ich fühle mich gut als else
franzose
wenn es darum geht recht zu sein sind
wir deutschen schon das original das
muss man das würde ich jetzt nicht da
ihr habt viele wachen erfunden
da muss der auf stolz sein sagt man dazu
kampfflieger also die deutschen darf
dürfen sich nicht schämen wir sind ein
problem ihr deutschen er schämt euch
immer immer über die geschichte also
oder da gibt's schon auch gründe muss
man sagen was nicht schon in der ganzen
welt ups krieg krieg gegeben
sie stoppt die ersten kz waren in
südafrika also ihr braucht jetzt nicht
also
sogar negativ zu sein gegenüber ihre
ihrer ihrer vergangenheit ich glaube die
hätten sich gut mit meinem großvater
verstanden
er hatte ähnliche ansichten war auch
länger beruflich in frankreich gibt es
parallelen kann man sagen dass die frau
national wähler die am rhein wo
reinrassig sind nicht von wasser info
national kennen ja nur die nationalität
das hat nichts zu tun mit wasser das hat
zu tun mit denen man wenn man franzose
hieß muss man französische ahnung haben
wenn man deutscher ist muss man sonst
deutsche einen haben
aber es können auch andere deutsche
werben die sich an das dass das deutsche
leben adaptieren assimilieren man muss
sich assimilieren
das ist das kriterium wie wie könnte ich
franzose werden wie könnte ich perfekt
assimiliert das wirklich akzeptieren
würde also zuerst einmal die sprache
vielleicht verbessern
und na ja sie haben ja schon einen einen
motor wieder total französisch ist also
sie werden in sechs monaten schon ein
franzose werden können können und sechs
monaten
das würde ich sagen woran machen sie das
abhängig also also das ist die schon die
begleitung
sie sind ein eleganter mann die sie
sprechen mit den frauen sie sie
verachten die frauen nicht sie haben
eine europäische kultur
wie sie ums prozent würde die front
national bekommen wenn sie nicht mit
irgendeiner blondine antreten würde
sondern mit dem richtigen kerl mit dem
richtigen kerl ich glaube ziemlich die
dieselbe anzahl an stimmen
generell kann ich ja auch in ordnung
wenn es einem vw die die dann wiederum
bisschen femininer ist also femininen
typ sowie werden töpfe zum beispiel sind
sie total zynisch was da werde ich keine
antwort geben werde
[Applaus]
ich habe ihn gesehen
also ich habe ihn im internet gesehen
dachte naja ich hörte ihn zu zwei
minuten lange und danach schaut sich
wieder auf die ohren dann war hatte er
schon 50 minuten gesprochen und david
sie eingeschlafen ist nach einer im
gegenteil könnt ihr bei ihm politisches
asyl beantragen
bei der freunder für die wii sowie das
wenn es denn so wäre sagen wir mal
könnte er jetzt durch werke klingelt er
einen politischen asyl beantragen in
frankreich und nicht ich würde das
selbstverständlich bei jahren als durch
für die sozusagen ok mexiko korea und
damit gebe ich zurück nach köln und
bernd werke wird dann demnächst mal
klingeln
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fotos
[Applaus]